durant ce webinaire je vais développer
avec vous un certain nombre de solutions
développées les fonds régionaux de
proximité réservé aux entrepreneurs pour
qu'ils constituent et qu'il renforce les
fonds propres de leur entreprise faire
de 2021 l'année des territoires
d'outre-mer avec la conquête des
touristes hexagonaux le développement de
l'économie endogène l'intensification
des relations internationales régionales
et la célébration des 60 ans du service
militaire adapté
il faut soutenir la productivité des
petites entreprises
simplification d'accès aux fonds
structurels soutien technique pour aider
à la modernisation préfinancement des
fonds structurels règlement à 30 jours
réel des factures par les collectivités
et aide à la constitution des fonds
propres
redistribution équitable des 320
millions d'euros annuels des fonds de
compensation possible au profit du
développement endogène
il faut réduire la part des filières
banane et canne à sucre actuellement
subventionnées à hauteur de 200 millions
d'euros par an il faut le faire au
profit des petites exploitations normes
alors là il faut sortir de la logique de
complexité il faut simplifier
drastiquement les normes
il faut les adapter à chaque territoire
voilà bonjour merci d'être venu à ce
webinaire pour parler de cette situation
très particulière suite au coronavirus
et je vais démarrer tout de suite par le
premier thème qui est coronavirus une
opportunité tout à fait inattendu pour
les territoires d'outre-mer
alors c'est effectivement une
opportunité économique mais c'est aussi
une opportunité sociale alors j'ai bien
conscience que c'est un discours
inattendu
la réalité c'est que le coronavirus
n'est en aucun cas une crise en tout cas
ce n'est pas une crise économique le
corps navires us c'est un tsunami
donc il y à une crise qui est une crise
sanitaire terrible avec les drames
terribles qui sont évidemment le
corollaire de cette crise
mais on va ensemble essayer d'entre eux
voir de quelle façon éviter maintenant
une crise sociale majeure
le cobp 8 10
huff est un tsunami car quand ils
passent ils cassent tout sur son passage
un tiers des entreprises en outre-mer
est en danger de mort un tiers des
entreprises ultramarines risque d'être
purement et simplement rayés de la carte
économique des territoires
un tsunami ça aussi la caractéristique
malheureusement de pouvoir revenir et
aujourd'hui avec le changement
climatique
avec la mondialisation avec la
négligence de l'environnement rien ne
dit qu'un nouveau virus ne pourrait pas
frapper encore l'humanité dans les
années à venir
donc c'est en cela que je suis convaincu
qu'il n'y aura jamais de retour à
l'antériorité sur veut réussir il nous
faut admettre que c'est maintenant la
norme même si je conviens qu'elle est
brutal et nouvelles c'est ce que nous
vivons à partir d'aujourd'hui dans le
cadre de la situation économique qui
nous est maintenant est posée par le
virus alors entre 7 et 8%
c'est la chute du produit intérieur brut
donc la chute de la richesse produite
par la france sur l'année 2020 c'est ça
la donne des territoires d'outre-mer
sont impactés de manière un peu
inférieur à peu près à hauteur de 5% ce
qui est d'ailleurs en trompe l'oeil
parce que dans la réalité il ya ce qu'on
appelle les stabilisateurs de l'économie
c'est à dire la richesse qui est
produite par l'administration qui est
extrêmement forte dans les territoires
si on la compare avec ce qu'elle est
dans la france hexagonale
je parle donc de stabilisateur en
trompe-l'oeil casse si on enlève la
présence de l'administration pour ne
voir que l'économie marchande
les chiffres sont les mêmes en
territoires ultramarins ou en france
hexagonale environ 8% de chute du pib
sur l'année 2020 mayotte malheureusement
sera impacté beaucoup plus gravement
cette nouvelle réalité suppose que
l'état va disposer de moins d'argent
moins d'argent pour tout le monde donc
moins d'argent pour les ultramarins
comment retourner la situation au profit
les outre-mers l'opportunité réside dans
deux grands axes le premier axe et
philosophique mais sa résonance
politique donc économique doit être
majeur
il faut définitivement placé toute
l'énergie disponible pour développer
économie endogène alors qu'est ce que ça
veut dire
jusqu'à maintenant on a un état central
qui distribue les grandes lignes est un
central et bruxelles pour expliquer à
chacune des régions
ce qu'elle doit faire dans les grands
axes or l'état jacobin et exotique pour
les ultramarins
malgré la décentralisation on assiste
quand même à une prégnance forte de
l'état
il faut sortir de cette logique de
complexité par exemple l'application des
normes
on ne peut plus admettre que la même
norme soit valable à maubeuge à mayotte
à qu'aion ou à cayenne ou à
fort-de-france pardon
à titre d'exemple la seule façon de
transporter des enfants en guyane pour
aller sur le fleuve à l'école c'est
d'utiliser des pirogues guyane c'est ou
là où l'avion ou l'hélicoptère ou la
pirogue ça marche comme ça depuis
toujours mais figurez-vous que la norme
française ou européenne
appliquée à tout le monde dit que les
fleuves guyanais ne sont pas navigables
or tout le monde sait qu'on avec dessus
personne ne prendrait évidemment le
risque politique d'interdire aux enfants
d'aller à l'école en pirogue
mais personne ne s'est posé la question
de savoir par exemple s'il valait pas
mieux faire une norme adapté à la guyane
ça permettrait au moins de bénéficier
des assurances nécessaires alors
toujours pour le développement de gênes
il faut se poser aussi très sérieusement
la question des sous la question des
fonds possible par exemple ces fonds de
compensation permettent de soutenir la
production agricole locale
agroalimentaire en tout cas ils sont à
peu près de 320 millions d'euros par an
ces 320 millions d'euros par an sont
préemptés par la banane martiniquaise à
raison de 96 millions d'euros par la
banane guadeloupéen à hauteur de 32
millions d'euros par la filière canne à
sucre réunionnaise à hauteur de 50
millions d'euros et pour la filière
canne à sucre rhum antillaise à hauteur
de 23 millions d'euros
le soutien massif de ces deux trois
cultures en intégrant leurs hommes en
préemptant plus de 60% des fonds pesé
c'est à dire plus de 200 millions
d'euros sur les 320 millions d'euros
nu l étrangle littéralement toute
capacité de développement économique des
filières endogène de l'agroalimentaire
en outre elle constitue un bénéfice j'ai
envie de vous dire allez un pognon de
dengue au profit d'une toute petite
minorité
la redoutable excellente association
euros d'hommes grand lobbyistes par
excellence veille à préserver
prioritairement les intérêts financiers
d'un tout petit groupe
alors où les propositions doivent
remonter à l'europe précisément pour les
prochains programme posei c'est à dire
maintenant avant le 31 mai est raide
hommes demandent au gouvernement de
sonner le tocsin sur cette question en
effet si les mêmes à rafle tout attrape
le même niveau de subventions pour les
années à venir
c'en est fini de tout espoir de
développement de l'agroalimentaire
endogène sur les territoires je reviens
à l'instant sur les 127 millions de
subvention donnée aux grandes familles
pour la banane antillaise qui peut qui
en réalité c'est en partie avec ses 127
millions ou j'en ai de l'émotion dans la
voix que ces grandes familles ont arrosé
la martinique et la guadeloupe durant
des années et des années avec cette
saloperie de chlordécone faut gagner
toujours plus toujours plus quitte à
souligner pour des siècles et des
siècles à terre quitte à semer cancer et
désolation le développement endogène
c'est donc le choix respecté par paris
des lignes de développement économiques
décidées dans chacun des territoires et
chacun sa façon de décider c'est d'en
finir avec l'économie de rente avec
autant de brutalité que le coït 19
s'emploie à détruire l'économie endogène
soutenir la banane soutenir la can
oui mais plus à n'importe quel prix à
titre de rappel un rapport extrêmement
sérieux qui a été remis dans les
ministères en 2018 fait état de la
possibilité de transformer intégralement
la canne à sucre et une yonnaise en
énergie en can énergie ça aurait pour
effet de servir le même revenu aux
planteurs sans avoir recours au fonds
européen
mais évidemment ça ferait absolument pas
les affaires du groupe tereos qui outre
les 50 millions d'euros des fonds
possible qu'ils récupèrent chaque année
a obtenu en 2015 une subvention annuelle
complémentaire de 20
9 millions d'euros le problème posé donc
un problème politique
ou bien on continue à soutenir
l'économie de rente au motif que l
emploi beaucoup de monde
1 c'est le motif principal c'est à dire
soutenir les riches au détriment de la
population
ou bien on se met autour de la table
face à face avec une volonté une volonté
ferme de faire triompher la justice
sociale et on y arrivera
c'est ça l'opportunité majeur offertes
par la nouvelle donne économique imposé
par la pandémie du coc vide 19 il ya un
deuxième grand axe c'est la santé
financière des cent cinquante mille
entreprises est de territoires
d'outre-mer alors à l'instar des
entreprises la france hexagonale
elles sont très largement sous
capitalisées la capitalisation des
entreprises
c'est n'est fondé son financier des
pour réussir il faut une idée beaucoup
de courage aux dirigeants beaucoup
d'abnégation du dirigeant du talent du
savoir faire mais il faut des sous il
faut aussi de l'argent vont permettre à
nos entreprises de sortir vainqueur de
cette nouvelle donne économique pour
permettre à nos créateurs d'entreprise
de saisir les nouvelles opportunités qui
vont être assurément de cette nouvelle
situation économique
il faut revoir il faut rendre performant
vraiment les dispositifs d aide à la
constitution des fonds propres il en
existe deux types les fip et les fonds
d'investissement de proximité qu'on
trouve notamment la réunion et aux
antilles et il y en a ailleurs aussi et
puis les cem les sociétés d'économie
mixte notamment ça marche comme ça en
nouvelle calédonie y en a trois cela
peut très bien marcher
il ya notamment un exemple très
intéressant avec le fip de la corse
voilà tout chef d'entreprise ayant
besoin de renforcer ses fonds propres
doit avoir accès à un fonds de
capitalisation
sans argent on n'arrive à rien il ya
aussi la formation il n'y a pas
d'économie vertueuse sans excellence de
la productivité la productivité elle
passe par l'accès à l'information et par
l'accès à la modernisation de l'outil de
travail
je le réaffirme clairement si nos
entreprises d'outre-mer reste sous
capitalisées elles n'ont absolument
aucune chance de saisir les nouveaux
les opportunités imposées par la
nouvelle donne économique
enfin je veux saluer la réactivité de
l'état sur la mise en place des
amortisseurs immédiat je parle du prêt
garantie d'état à hauteur de 300
milliards d'euros qui a été immédiat je
parle de l'indemnité de compensation de
1500 euros pour les petites entreprises
je parle du report des charges je parle
des prêts complémentaires qui ont été
mises en place également par les
conseillers régionaux pardon et je parle
aussi de la mobilisation citoyenne qui
existent pour soutenir notre économie
ça c'est une réalité qui fait chaud au
coeur mais les systèmes restent
totalement perfectible notamment pour ce
qui est de la moitié des entreprises
ultramarines qui ne sont pas à jour ou
de leurs charges sociales ou de leurs
impôts donc du coup elles n'ont pas
droit à ces à ses amortisseurs
mais elle aussi il faut leur venir en
aide
l'association est raide hommes
république et développement trop maire
propose à toutes les entreprises qu'ils
demandent son concours pour aider à la
rédaction des dossiers d'attribution des
aides
le développement endogène a aussi un
caractère national
je vise la une des économies les plus
impactés c'est l'économie du tourisme
il faut inciter maintenant tout de suite
maintenant tous nos concitoyens de
france hexagonale à venir passer leurs
vacances dans les merveilleux
territoires français d'outre-mer je vous
assure qu'ils y seront très
fraternellement accueillis ils y
découvriront ces différences magnifique
environnementale les gens qui sont
tellement gentil tellement chaud qui ont
aussi leur histoire et sa ses propres à
chaque territoire en guyane c'est
quelque chose en martinique c'est autre
chose
en polynésie française c'est autre chose
et pour les onze territoires c'est autre
chose
moi je ne doute pas une seule seconde
comme moi il ya quarante ans le virus
merveilleux virus alors celui ci le bo
virus d outre-mer voix m'a piqué ça fait
40 ans que je vis dans le nom dans le
dans l'amour de ses territoires
d'outre-mer que je crois connaître un
petit peu j'en apprends tous les jours
chaque fois que je suis reçu chaque fois
j'ouvre encore mes yeux et j'y vais
malgré tout extrêmement souvent alors ce
que j'ai envie
pour moi c'est que la grandeur de la
guyane de mayotte de wallis et futuna de
saint martin la réunion de la polynésie
française il faut pas que j'en oublie de
saint barth de la martinique de la
nouvelle calédonie saint pierre et
miquelon et la guadeloupe à la
guadeloupe encore est raide homme
propose de faire de l'année 2000 21
l'année du touriste en outre-mer 2021
année du tourisme dans notre mère est
raide on me propose que dès maintenant
chacun de nos onze territoires du
pacifique de l'atlantique de l'océan
indien soit aidée pour lancer d'abord
une campagne de promotion auprès de nos
concitoyens de la france hexagonale mais
il faut aussi les aider à se structurer
pour pouvoir avoir les capacités
d'accueil
il faut les aider également à à faire en
sorte qu'ils aient suffisamment d'argent
pour être prêt parce que c'est
maintenant la maintenant qu'on doit se
préparer maintenant si on veut
accueillir des visiteurs qui vont
arriver début début 2000 21 ou cours en
on va pas penser fabriquer quelque chose
de peu pour l'accueil la veille au soir
dont tu es maintenant la voyez il ya une
fabuleuse énergie à m m
il faut la mettre tout de suite donc moi
je dis aujourd'hui que le soutien
politique est indispensable
la confiance sans laquelle rien n'est
possible est indispensable c'est
vraiment ensemble qu'on va y arriver
je veux vraiment vous faire partager
cette conviction je fais partie des gens
qui je crois connaissent un peu lente
reprise
cette nouvelle donne il faut franchement
qu'on y aille
il faut qu'on y aille avec ces nouvelles
règles il faut s'appuyer à fond sur la
richesse de chacun des territoires il
faut qu'ils soient tous différencier il
faut qu'on pousse l'économie endogène
il faut que on arrive à soutenir cette
économie cette petite économie parce que
cette petite économie c'est chacun
d'entre nous qui est concerné par cela
voilà c'était mon premier thème je voulu
être assez court parce qu'un deuxième
thème derrière karim dont je vais vous
parler dans quelques secondes d'après un
tout petit intermède le temps de boire
un verre d'eau et puis peut-être de
prendre certaines de vos questions
le deuxième
l'appareil sera court à peu près 15
minutes puis après je me livrerai à
toutes les réponses auxquelles je peux
peut-être apporter je peux peut-être
apporter des quelques idées voilà bien
écoute à tout de suite dans une petite
minute